I'm Kai lukoff assistant professor at
Santa Clair University and today I'll be
presenting on designing to support sense
of agency for time spent on digital
devices or digital interfaces I'll also
say that yeah I'm very honored as
Michael mentioned that this uh work
received the sikai um 2020 3 outstanding
dissertation award and that's the basis
of what I'm going to talk about
today so let's dive in um computers are
everywhere in our modern environment and
of course this offers great benefits in
the form of access to information
communication and entertainment at our
fingertips however this constant access
to computers also means that Temptations
for distraction are
everywhere and
one useful way to define Temptations is
as desires that conflict with a person's
long-term goals and people often attempt
to resist such Temptations but they
often
fail and so for example um when people
attempt to resist Temptations such as
smoking drinking or shopping they fail
around 30% of the time According to some
experience sampling studies um
however the Temptation with the highest
failure rate of all is Media use where
people fail about 75% of the time and
with a computer in our pocket nowadays
uh this temptation to engage with media
use is always with us and hard to
resist so of course the attention
economy and this practice of monetizing
people's attention uh arose over a
century ago with newspapers and radio
but the smartphone has really
dramatically enhance the Arsenal of
attention
Merchants uh and because of the high
rate of smartphone ownership and its
close proximity to the user at all times
devices on our apps or our apps can
really capture our attention at any time
and any place and second apps can Target
highly specific demographics so female
mmpg gamers in New York City uh that
would have been difficult to reach in
the past and Al Ms can of course
leverage this kind of granular tracking
to Target content and ads that seduce
the individual
user the result is that digital digital
technology today is associated with a
number of what I would call attentional
harms that is from distractions when
driving and socializing to a loss of
productivity and sleep and individually
the shortterm costs may seem small but
given the amount of time that we now
spend online I'd argue that that these
costs can really add up to undermine our
goals and
values and technology companies often
want people to believe that their
inability to control their technology
use is due to a lack of
willpower however the reality is that
companies that are purposefully
developing technologies that exploit
psychological vulnerabilities to capture
our
attention and so for example in the
popular social media game Farmville
there's this pattern that when you
attempt to leave the game you're
notified that if you don't return within
a certain period of time your crops are
going to wither and
die this ad on it has a this has a fake
hair on it that prompts the user to
click into that uh particular ad um and
you know of course when you try and
brush it off that's what
happens and so you might think of uh
these types of design patterns as what
could be called Dark patterns or user
interfaces that are intentionally
designed to trick users into doing
things that go against their best
interests and so far designers have
documented dark patterns that cause
Financial harms privacy harms uh but
really little about this category of
attentional harms and so my work
systematically examines attention
capture dark
patterns uh and so given all of the user
frustrations with a loss of control what
should designers actually be designing
for so in my dissertation work um I
focused on the sense of agency the
experience of control over one's actions
and their outcomes in the world and I
think of sense of agency as a promising
lens for this work because uh providing
sense of agency of course is a principal
design juristic uh in many sort of HCI
guidelines but and then um second high
sense of agency is really associated
with positive technology use outcomes
and third I'd argue that sense of agency
matters in its own right that is in
self-determination Theory it um is kind
of one of the the core principles of
what leads to well-being and
fulfillment and so my investigation of
this digital environment that Fosters
such a loss of control has led me to
these three statements um and the first
is that existing screen time tools
provide insufficient control um for
users to Target the specific experiences
with mobile apps that they find
problematic and second we can identify
specific design features Within These
mobile apps that influence sense of
agency and finally by redesigning mobile
apps to support a greater control or
greater sense of agency in the right
context we can help users align their
app use with their goals for
use Okay so let's talk a little bit
about the methods that I employ in my
research uh as an HCI systems researcher
you are probably familiar with this as
an HCI group but I'll cover it in brief
and I think of my work in HCI systems
research as proceeding from developing
some understanding of the user or a
problem and I might use data driven
interviews or experience sampling to do
so then I'd proceed to some phase of
design or co-design or prototyping might
be methods there
and then on to building and that could
be something like a mobile app or
browser extension and finally to
evaluating and so there I might use an
experiment or a field deployment and so
I've published across all of these
different methods um at some of the
different HCI
venues and of course though I'll say
that is a very sort of linear view of
how this works and in practice it often
looks something more uh like this where
you kind of circle around and you find
that you've built something that doesn't
actually meet those user needs and so
you go back to user understanding and so
forth and so my talk then also is going
to though don't worry follow this linear
narrative to make things a little bit
clearer and so the first question that
we'll take on is what app use makes
people feel a loss of sense of
agency we'll go to what design features
within apps can we change to support
sense of agency
and then finally do alternative versions
of these apps support sense of agency in
the
wild so let's dive
in so smartphone users often describe
their uses of mobile apps as pleasurable
um but that they can distract from some
of their Higher Goals and so for example
checking on those dying crops in
Farmville might be fun but take away
from a lunch with friends or a
challenging programming assignment and
so so one way to understand this problem
is through the lens of Aristotelian
virtue ethics and many smartphone apps
appear to be excellent in this context
of providing hedonia or maximizing what
feels good right now but uh as the Greek
philosopher Aristotle pointed out um or
proposed udonia or growing through
challenging and um experiences that that
bring meaning is also a really important
component of our well-being and then the
question becomes in today's era how can
we create digital environments that
support meaningful experiences and
digital
well-being uh so this is work that I
published with my colleague CCU uh Julie
ke and Alexis Hiner at ubic comp and we
asked what makes smartphone use
meaningful or
meaningless and prior research in this
area has relied primarily on user
interviews in the past and um we
realized that we could use the
experience sampling method here
uh to send the user a short survey at
the exact moment of interest in terms of
their smartphone app use and uh capture
some of their Inu
data and so here's a diagram of the
study protocol that we used but when our
study app detected the user using an app
on their phone say Facebook uh we would
then randomly detect some uh select some
sort of timing so at the start of app
use during app use or at the end of app
use and administer and uh experience
sing question which in our case was how
much do you feel like you have spent
your time on something meaningful and
have participants rate that
experience yeah was that just a
notification you sent on the phone or
how did that work yeah exactly it was a
pop it was actually a popup inside of
the app so so you just use the glass PT
and Drew on top of the app exactly
yeah
um in terms of study data then we
collected 86,000 samples of app use from
45 Android smartphone users and at the
end we conducted 11 datadriven exit
interviews uh and in these exit
interviews what we did is we um created
these little cuts of the users's data um
during the experience or study and
presented it back to them and we wanted
to use that so that we could really get
at the sort of why behind some of the
ratings that they had experienced um
rather than just getting sort of the
aggregate
data and so what type of app use did
participants find meaningful or
meaningless well participants shared
that when they used apps for
productivity the experience was mostly
meaningful um and here we found that
participants sort of thought of
productivity broadly defined so not just
like work productivity but also like
being able to do something socially
productive um and one participant
explained that they had rated the slack
app as a seven out of seven for
meaningfulness and said it's meaningful
in that way because it helps me get work
done easier communication was another
appuse that was seen as meaningful most
of the time and one participant said I
didn't speak to my daughter at Le for at
least 5 days and then yesterday she
finally talked to me on Facebook so
that's why I put a six out of seven for
meaningfulness um and when asked what
type of use they found less meaningful
participants often highlighted passive
social media use so whereas on the
previous slide a participant used
Facebook for communication and rated it
high for meaningfulness here another
participant rated it low and they said
going to Facebook just to browse and not
doing anything else that's pretty much
meaningless entertainment was also
experienced as less meaningful in
general and a participant here shared I
wouldn't say any time spent on that game
was meaningful it's just a way to
entertain myself
mindlessly so here's some of that
aggregate data and what we found if we
look at meaningfulness on the Y AIS and
type of use on the x-axis we can see
that
productivity information and
communication are all above uh kind of a
four on our seveno scale and then
there's some difference between the
other two categories of entertainment
and social media which are both below
3.5 um and so that data yeah what
delineates communication versus social
media and that's like I can imagine
maybe like Discord would be in a fuzzy
area same with Facebook Messenger yeah
that's a great question I didn't cover
that here but we actually had
participants in addition to that earlier
experience sampling question that we um
had on a seven-point scale self-describe
what you know which of these use cases
they felt their app use fell into
because uh and I don't cover this here
we did know going into this that
participants often use the same app for
different purposes so particularly apps
like Facebook or WeChat that are kind of
the sprawling empires of all kinds of
different Services can be used for say
information communication entertainment
you know all these kind of different use
cases so that's where we had
participants self
self-described um and so this told us
about the averages but we also saw a lot
of individual variation in the data um
and we found that the same sort of
category or type of use could sometimes
be meaningful and sometimes not and so
for example one father often played the
game Candy Crush on his phone uh which
he usually rated low in meaningfulness
but in this case he actually rated it as
a seven out of seven for meaningfulness
and he explained um you can't step
outside for a minute each time it gets
hectic because it's always hectic with
three children which I can now identify
as the father of two children uh two
young children um so I use Candy Crush
to uplift myself and relax um and so in
other words Candy Crush Was sometimes
meaningful in this context as a relief
from stressful
situations finally another major theme
that came up over and over again was
that participants really felt a loss of
control that led to negative effects and
so one part participant described an
example of such unconscious phone use
where they said without even realizing
it I pulled out my phone and just
started mindlessly checking my email and
when I put it away I realized oh I feel
bad for ignoring my friends
so what are some of the takeaways from
these yeah go ahead um I'm wondering if
meaningfulness here is appr proxy for
satisfaction or if that is different if
you looked at that and kind of interact
with perceptions of
meaningfulness yeah so we didn't ask
about meaningfulness and satisfaction
separately um I kind of wish we had have
done something like that and we do kind
of do something like that in the third
study that I'm going to present where we
ask separately about satisfaction and um
whether or not something aligned with a
person's long-term goals and so we'll
get to see the results on that in a few
minutes yeah good point yeah another
detail question the you say you either
sort of when they launch the app in the
middle of it or at the end so what
happens if I'm using Facebook or
something like that and then I just lock
the screen like and and put away my
phone does it prevented from locking the
screen and make me answer the question
first or is the after only working if I
sort of swipe the app away and I'm about
to open something else the lad yeah it
only works if you swipe the app away and
uh yeah got about to do something else
and we can still send it yep
thanks um so what are some of the
takeaways then from this this work here
um well first meaning depends upon
context uh and so the same type of app
use is not a reliable indicator of
meaningfulness is what we
found and so Candy Crush as
um a relief from stressful
situations um
and the same app also was not uh
sometimes rated as meaningful and
sometimes not so this gets to that
question of like these categories don't
always work the same way um and then
finally uh a loss of control really led
to meaningless use as well and so when
we started looking at um this issue more
um we really realized that this actually
is Central to sort of this concern
around digital well-being um and we
found this wasn't just because a lack of
control leads to negative effects um but
also because there's I think this
inherent drive to want and need to feel
like you have the ability to influence
the world around you um and so lack if
lack of control is a problem uh then
what what can designers and computer
scientists do about
this
um well so far I would say concern
concerned practitioners um have really
responded with what I'd call Screen Time
tools um which are now pre-installed on
every single Android and iOS device so
here you can see the Apple screen time
and Google's digital
well-being um but one implication of my
findings on meaningfulness is that these
tools are really too crude um they
really use these external features that
operate the same way across all kinds of
apps
um such as lockout mechanisms and timers
um to block access to
apps um the concern though is that
you're actually going to end up
indiscriminately blocking access to
meaningful experiences for users and
that might might also lead users to
abandon the tools in the first place so
what might designers and developers do
instead um well one alternative approach
is to change the design of the inter
internal features inside of apps rather
than blocking apps altogether and so
this means identifying features within
apps such as recommendations autoplay
and search to understand which ones
support or undermine sense of agency and
so that's the challenge that we
addressed in my next
research so now that we've gained an
understanding of some of the user needs
and identified an alternative approach
to current screen time tools this brings
us to this question
of um what design features within apps
can we change to support sense of
agency um so this is work that I
published with my colleagues ol Lings
Zade Vera Leo James TR caou fun um sha
mson and Alexis Hiner at kai2 and we
decided to focus on YouTube and ask this
question of what design features
influence sense of agency within the
YouTube mobile
app and we selected YouTube as a test
case because uh it was one of those apps
that we found to be meaningful at
sometimes and not meaningful at other
times in that first study uh and it has
similar features to of course many other
social media apps in terms of
recommendations autoplay and search and
third it has a public API that we could
down the road um build an alternative
client for watching YouTube videos and
so stay tuned about that um in our first
study we really wanted to understand
which exist in features within the
YouTube mobile app influence sense of
control and so um to investigate this
question we conducted a survey with 120
participants all YouTube users from the
us and our primary question here was was
um what are three things about the
mobile app that lead you to feel more in
control over how you spend your time on
YouTube and conversely um what are three
things about the mobile app that lead
you to feel um least in control over how
you spend your
time um and so then we established a
code book with multiple coders um and
established our inner R reliability to
analyze which features really
contributed to sense of control in One
Direction or the
other and so here's what we found um we
found this diverging bar chart um which
is ordered in terms of um design
features that are rated or mentioned
most frequently by participants so with
recommendations being mentioned by
almost everyone um down to Notifications
coming up less
frequently uh and the features that
primarily LED participants to feel least
in control were recommendations ads and
autoplay and then the ones that made
people feel most in control were
playlists search subscriptions watch
history and stats and play
controls so let's take a look at how
recommendations LED participants to feel
less in control so one survey
participant said I have a hard time not
looking at the suggested videos that the
algorithm picks for me I almost always
justify watching just one more
video and on the other hand let's look
at an example of a feature that made
survey participants feel a little more
in control and that's playlists and so
one participant wrote uh I can create
playlists or CU videos in advance to
limit what I watch to a specific list
instead of endlessly searching around
for what I want and so as compared to
searching around several participants
also noted that playlists really have a
clear end um and so that served as a
stopping cue to um serve as a signal for
them to finish their session of use on
YouTube so in the second part of uh this
study we really wanted to understand
what changes to the features of YouTube
might increase sense of control
and so we conducted two code design
activities with YouTube users uh the
first was a sketching exercise um and we
asked participants to sketch a version
of the interface of the mobile app that
would me make them feel most in control
and one that would make them feel least
in
control um and so you can see in the
example for Less control it's sort of
plastered with lots of different videos
um and here they wrote you need to
scroll down to see the search bar at the
very bottom of the app by contrast here
they wanted to move the search bar to
the very top and sort of limited the
recommendations to things that were
already directly interested to things
that the user had explored
previously the second code design
activity that we engaged with um was
evaluating mock-ups of different
versions of YouTube that were designed
from our perspective to support
different levels of control and so for
example here were three different
versions of how recommendations might
work you could have unlimited recommend
commendations which is basically the
current interface you could have like
three recommendations and click to show
more videos or you could have no
recommendations and we wanted to get
feedback on users on these
interfaces um and so one of the
interesting findings then was um that
recommendations were a top concern for
all of our survey participants and
codesign participants and they really
Express frustration with their inability
to customize their location quantity and
content uh and this was in the in
particular the case uh where
participants found recommendations to be
kind of too tempting or too good in that
they conflicted with their other goals
um at that moment in time um and so one
participant said when I'm tempted but no
a video is not educational I can hide it
using the not interested but uh option
and so I think this is pretty
interesting because in this case the
participant is really reappropriate this
not interested button for a different
reason and saying in fact this is really
interesting but not now um I want to
actually be watching say educational
content or learning how to cook a
specific
recipe um the second major finding from
our code design is that when
participants reviewed the different
versions of their own sketches in our
mockups they were often conflicted about
just how much control they preferred it
depended upon the use case and they
preferred different levels of control
for each so one participant here said if
I have a specific goal I know what I
want I don't need recommendations to
guide my search I just want to be in
control of my
search by contrast when the same
participant did not have a specific
intention in mind they said if I just
want to watch something that gets my
mind off of things I prefer the one
where I can choose to show more
recommendations and so the implication
then is that for different use cases
participants prefer different levels of
control and when they had a specific
intent ention in mind such as watching a
tutorial to complete a Rubik's Cube they
wanted more control um and when they did
not have a specific intention in mind
they just wanted to relax or pass the
time then they really wanted to lean
back and let YouTube take
control so what are some of the
implications for design here well based
on these findings um one implication
would be to adapt the interface to the
specificity of the user's intention so
for example when the user has a specific
intention uh the design might present a
search first interface on the other hand
when the user has no specific intention
the designer might uh present a
recommendations first
interface and then switching between
these interfaces you know is something
that offers some
potential so to recap the takeaways from
our study of the features within the
YouTube app where um we first gain sort
of this knowledge of self-reported
um sense of control when using different
features and undermining control where
recommendations adds in autoplay and
supporting control where playlist search
and
subscriptions uh the second was that we
can provide users with different levels
of control for different
situations so then armed with this
knowledge of specific design features
within apps that affect sense of control
can we build alternative versions of
these apps that support sense of agency
in the
wild
well um that's what we wanted to turn to
in our final study here um and so this
is work that I presented at the kai
conference this year um the switch tube
study and we asked you know can we
redesign social media apps to support
digital well-being and again we used
YouTube as a test
case so I'll start by showing um a quick
demo video of the
app so switch tube is an Android app um
and it allows users to or allows us to
study design patterns that affect the
user experience uh and study
participants experience three different
versions explore focus and switch and so
here's explore which was designed to
undermine user sense of agency and it's
similar in its features to the official
YouTube app so you can see the homepage
is recommendations first it's plastered
with all kinds of recommendations we
have the search return entertaining
results so you can see how to fix a flat
Tire returns kind of these
uh recommendations here um and when the
video finishes the next video starts
autop playing
automatically the focus version was
designed to support user agency based on
our prior
findings and we had a search first
homepage and the search returned
relevant
results
and there were no video recommendations
and no autoplay when you went to watch a
particular
video and finally we created a switch
version and that let users toggle back
and forth between the Explorer and the
focus
version um and so we called this switch
version um a adaptable commitment
interface uh which we defined as an
interface where um the user can commit
to stay focused on their intention by
blocking out distractions but also has
the option to toggle um that version
off and so we had some competing
hypothesis for how we thought this might
work in the wild um and one was that it
could provide sort of The Best of Both
Worlds that is you know you could choose
the scenarios in which you wanted to um
use Focus mode and the others in which
you wanted to
explore um but the other was that a lot
of the way that screen time tools
function is via commitment devices and
it could be that just being able to
easily toggle over to an explore mode
would pose too much Temptation and be
too easy to kind of circumvent any sort
of
controls and so then our research
questions were when and why do
participants toggle between focus and
explore
mode and how does this adaptable
commitment interface affect user
experience
metrics um and so that's actually where
we get a little bit into this question
of sort of sense of agency and
satisfaction and goal alignment which we
tried to measure separately from each
other in the experience sampling that we
did for this
study uh our study participants then
were 46 us YouTube users um they were
generally relatively heavy YouTube users
um and so spent 87 minutes per day on
the service um which interestingly
though is not that different from what
YouTube at least reports is their uh
median for a signed in user of 60
minutes per day
um and our study protocol um was such
that we had the participants install the
switch Tube app on their phone uh and
then they would be randomized into one
of our three different version or two
different versions explore focus and
finally we always had switch come at the
end because we wanted people to
experience that after they'd um
experienced the two versions and knew
sort of what they were toggling in
between um and then we conducted
datadriven exit
interviews so here again we used that
method of experience sampling um reusing
sort of the same infrastructure that we'
built um and we asked questions such as
for this if use of switch tube how much
did you feel in or out of control to
measure uh sense of agency for
instance um okay so what did we find
well surprisingly for us participants
did not spend more time in Explorer
there wasn't sort of a very um sign
there was no significant difference uh
in terms of time spent in the app um
what we did find though was that um uh
participants spent more time with each
video that they watched in the focus
condition than videos in the Explorer
condition where they were likely to
watch sort of more different videos for
a shorter
duration unsurprisingly um homepage
recommendations and related videos below
the current video were a popular source
of videos when participants were in
explore by comparison watching videos
from search results was popular in focus
and in switch there was some balance
between the two suggesting that
participants used features from both of
these
versions um and so in the switch version
when and why did participants actually
toggle between focus and explore mode
well we analyzed data from logs and
interviews and identified um four
distinct use cases that characterize
switching behavior and I'm going to
present two of those use cases with you
today so first participants switched to
address situational needs um and so one
participant said if I'm searching for
something like flat tire I go with Focus
because that seems to be more
educational um explores definitely more
entertainment and so in other words
participants did sometimes use switch
tube for the use case that we had
originally designed
for second an unanticipated use case
that was interesting to us was that
participants frequently toggled between
focus and explore within the same
session of use and so one parti here
said I used Focus to search for a
particular video when I was done
watching and I would turn on explore
sometimes um when I felt like looking
for recommended results underneath and
so the way that we sort of saw this
playing out in the data were that
participants would sort of start in
Focus mode um and make their search for
example for a cake decorating um to
avoid distractions um for their original
intention and then they would toggle
over once they had a cake decorating
video to the explore mode see more
recommendations for cake decorating and
watch more cake decorating
videos um and so then our second
research question here was um how does
an adaptable commitment interface affect
user experience
metrics and so we looked at sens of
agency um how much participants felt in
control of the use of the app and our
hypotheses based on our previous survey
and codesign with YouTube users where
that switch would provide the Best of
Both Worlds followed by Focus and then
explore and so our actual results found
that switch and focus were both rated
highly uh significantly higher than
explore um according to this pair wised
will Cox and rank test um with a
correction for multiple comparisons that
we conducted and so here you can really
see um the different averages in terms
of ratings between um the 46
participants in our study um and our
hypothesis about which designs would
support sense of agency here were mostly
supported I would say one participant
said in explore I felt like I had no
control because it was only the videos
that were there uh and search was not
working very well and so I was limited
to what somebody else chose for
me okay and so next we examine
satisfaction
um and so this was how much participants
felt Satisfied by the use of the app and
so here our hypotheses were that um
switch would again have the highest
rating but we thought that explore would
actually be greater than Focus because
recommendations would provide short-term
satisfaction that users sometimes
want um our actual results found that
switch was greater than Focus uh and
that Focus was actually greater than
explore uh and so what participants told
us here was that switch did satisfy my
needs more just because I had the option
to switch between different modes um
even if you don't use it having it is
always
good um finally We examined goal
alignment um and so we asked
participants like how much that uh use
case or that session of use um aligned
with their goals for use um and our
hypotheses here were that it would be
switch followed by Focus followed by
explore uh and our actual results found
that switch and focus were both rated
higher than explore and here a
participant said I liked how in focus it
was just the video and nothing else
there were no comments to read no
suggested videos on the bottom to scroll
through so I feel like I was very
focused on that one video that I was
watching so yeah sorry just a a detail
question yeah um a descriptive statistic
how often were was your say median
participant toling between you know
exploring Focus mode they you know you
gave some examples where they would do
it a lot within a session I'm just
curious in practice how much these folks
did yeah um it was a median of nine
times per week um for participants so a
little more than once a day yeah um
there was wide variation though there
were some participants who seemed to use
it a lot like within a single session
and some participants who it seemed like
the pattern was they tried it out a
little bit at the very beginning when
they first um got to the switch version
and then they were like okay I'm done
with this I'm just gonna you know use
this one version so yeah any sense of
what might have separated those two
groups that's a really good question
um I don't know I'd have to reflect on
it a little bit more thank you thanks
yeah you the test that you use here to
analyze the data again yeah it was a
will coxen sign ring test um with a
correction for multiple comparisons and
um we have that in the uh paper as well
um yeah thank
you and actually um in in hindsight uh I
think that was probably not the right uh
test to do um we could have done um I
think it's stepen Schuler was pointing
this out to me um when I presented this
work at at Kai but there's uh because we
did have not just a a hypothesis in
terms of comp comparison between groups
we actually had like a comparison um or
a hypothesis in terms of the comparison
of like how we thought the three
different levels would play out um I
think I forget what um test it was but
there was another one that would
actually be a better fit for this
scenario if I had to do it again but we
also pre-registered this so we were a
little little hesitant to actually like
then go back and uh and do it but I'd be
curious to run that analysis again
because like for some of these we find
that uh there's no significance
difference like here here but there is
between these two and this and so like
but it seems to me at least generally
there's this you know steady Trend
between all three conditions and you
were treating this as non parametric
data it's yeah non nonparametric yeah
exactly
yep so um in terms of overall discussion
um I think the term adaptable commitment
interface can seem like kind of a
paradox you know how can one commit if
one can easily switch away from that
commitment at any time um and yet with
our switch version we really found that
participants reported a higher sense of
agency satisfaction and go alignment
even though that explore mode was only a
toggle away um and so what we think is
that switch really worked as an
adaptable commitment interface because
it avoided triggers for distraction in
the first place um and this aligns with
an emerging consensus in the psych I
olical research that people who are
effective self-regulators do so by
avoiding Temptations altogether rather
than by resisting via willpower you know
staring down that cookie um in the
moment um and so I think one clear
design implication is that users would
often benefit from what you could call a
focus mode even within an app such as
YouTube uh that's commonly regarded as a
service for entertainment but in reality
does serve different use
cases and it also advances sense of
agency as a new lens for understanding
and designing for digital well-being in
contrast to this screen time Paradigm
that I think has been dominant thus
far um because ultimately I think what
we're designing for shouldn't be just to
limit overall time spent on the screen
but rather to empower you users to use
technology as they would like in um the
right time and the right
context um and so with that I'd like to
thank my many many collaborators across
computer science engineering design
information psychologist and psychology
who've made this work possible um and
how are we doing on time here I can
either okay
um let
i' I'd love to introduce actually one
other sort of New Direction of research
briefly that I've taken on um at Santa
Clara University because uh that's also
an area where uh I'd love to find some
potential collaborators um so yeah a
year ago uh I joined Santa Clair
University as an assistant professor in
computer science and engineering uh and
um that's allowed me to take on also
some new dire questions in my research
um I'll also note that you know we're
your neighbors here and uh we're
recruiting for PhD and post talks in my
lab as well as hiring five assistant uh
professors in computer science and
engineering so if you're a graduating
student that might be of interest to you
too um and so the new project that I
wanted to highlight then was um
co-designing the Toman aloney augmented
reality tour um and so what we're doing
here is um that Santa Clara University
has the Mission Santa Clara um and it's
really an active site of the Catholic
faith there are symbols of Catholicism
all over our campus um and the story of
our campus is really told from a
Catholic point of
view however the story of people um on
our campus really starts thousands of
years ago before Spanish colonizers and
American settlers ever arrived on the
land um and it starts with the alone
people who've been there and of course
the aloney people are still there today
and so we have our first uh aloney
student actually um at C clir University
this year who's been helping us on this
project which is very
exciting and so we wanted to ask sort of
how can we tell this aloney story on our
campus and so we brought together an
interdisciplinary team with faculty from
CS anthropology English um and the Arts
uh to do some of this work in
conjunction with the MMA alone
tribe um and so I wanted to show a short
clip of um the experience that we
actually just launched on um Monday as
part of indigenous people's day um I
might need to turn on the audio here
quickly so let me see if I can get that
to
work okay should be enabled now so let's
give it a
shot thian gram welcome to the center of
thian village for thousands of years our
ancestors called thian home once an oak
Woodland with year round water sources
this Village likely had 300 to 500
native
inhabitants
I can somehow never seem to advance the
slides without exiting the
presentation um and so yeah we just
launched that experience um on things
are helpful to restore and heal our
community Monday and we had the comea
that we've endured but it also to show
that there's still lot of work to be
done not only here but in the Bay Area
as a whole part of that work is to
highlight that these tribe members are
still here and the university is using
technology to do that several Santa
Clair University departments partnered
with aloney tribes once native to the
land this campus is on to bring their
stories to life with the use of
augmented reality on cell phones for
thousands of years our ancestors called
thian home the thian aloney AR tour
transforms the SCU campus back to what
it was thousands of years ago three
stops on the tour were launched Monday
but soon visitors will be able to scan
QR codes across campus to learn the
stories that these tribe members want
people to never
forget um and so in that work then um
what we've been working on is kind of
thinking of new code design methods for
how we might create augmented reality
experiences with communities um and so
here you can see one of the methods that
we've been working on and we we've been
calling landmark-based Affinity
diagramming so traditional Affinity
diagramming being kind of on a on a wall
um and instead we wanted to create a
giant map of our campus and have people
put different stories in different
locations where they thought those
stories would fit as well as different
media assets like recordings or 3D
models and other content in appropriate
locations that we can create these tour
stops for on our
campus and um of course this work is
actually inspired in part by one of the
projects um that took place on this
campus the dear visitor project which
was um
a physical plaque um or a plaque that
was
um uh for um Chanel Miller a sexual
assault Survivor um to recognize her and
was first created um digitally um and
shown in augmented reality become before
becoming a um physical plaque on this
campus later
on um and so ultimately what we're
hoping to do through this work is to
create an ar2 toolkit for social justice
tours that can Empower Educators and
storytellers um at multiple different
locations to create alternative tours
that really tell um or challenge um
traditional
narratives so I think I'll wrap up there
and
um leave time for some questions about
um my work on digital well-being as well
as if you have any feedback or
suggestions for this new direction of
augmented reality that we're also
exploring in my lab um would love to
hear from you so thank
[Applause]
you all right we have some time for
questions comments
feedback yeah I think you might have
mentioned this but I maybe didn't catch
it um so for the users that actually
toggle in switch between the versus the
focus how much time do they spend on
each so I'm just trying to think you
know if they had an illusion up
agency um or um by just having the
switch there or if they actually were in
control of um how much time you wanted
to spend there
you yeah um so we know how often they
switched and we know how how how much
time they spent in each of the
conditions unfortunately because of the
way we set up the logs we in the end
weren't able to actually EAS IL find out
how much time they spent like split
between the two conditions um when they
were in the switch version um but I
think you you raise an important concern
like whether this is actual agency or
maybe the illusion of agency because you
can sort of give people controls of
course where you know they press the
elevator button and they think they're
doing something but it doesn't actually
do anything like it doesn't affect how
soon the elevator um doors close
um and so I suppose that that's where we
were trying to get at this question by
asking you know how well it aligned with
their long-term goals for use and you'd
want to sort of you know triangulate
that with the more granular data of you
know how they're using um the app on a
day-to-day basis because you know at
least according to the definition of
sense of agency that we're working on um
it should be that the person has some
control over the outcomes in their life
and so you know if they're consistently
rating it as okay now the app is
supporting my sort of longer term goals
for use that seems like a good measure
in my mind of how you might get at that
question if you were to make like an
edited like final version of the tool
after having run this evaluation like
the best version would you like choose
one of those three would you make tweaks
on one of them like is there kind of a
like best recommendation you have for
how this tool should be helping people
towards their Vision I guess yeah um I'm
hoping to soon present to the go uh
digital well-being team at Google
actually and I think from s these user
experience metrics at least I would
recommend having a a switch um mode or
some sort of a focus mode that users
could enable even for this service like
YouTube um and I know personally I would
find that pretty useful at times when I
just want to go on YouTube and perform
one task um rather than you know getting
sucked into content that I would say
isn't necessarily even like vile or
clickbait right there's that too
sometimes but it's just not sort of it's
optimized for this local goal of like
what is the most interesting thing that
I could possibly show Kai um as opposed
to this larger question that I probably
have which is like you know is the right
thing for me to do or the thing I want
to be doing now watching another YouTube
video and more often than not um the
answer is
no can you go more into detail on how
you use the hbi to create
s yeah uh I'll say it was a battle
because uh we
um we had used it previously um Dr hener
my co-advisor on several studies and at
that time you could have I think like a
quote of 10 million uh API units or
calls
um and that was basically enough to do
anything you wanted and then somehow
after we embarked on this project we
realized that quota had been reduced to
about 10,000 and I think a a single
search cost like a 100 units of our
quota and so we were severely restricted
um in just using that and we had to
Cobble it together with this other like
um API that they provide Google custom
search which we used for the searches
separately so we had to integrate two um
different AP I which was a pain um
despite actually also like having lots
of contacts at Google and like reaching
out to them but they couldn't change the
policy and issue us more credits or we
couldn't even pay for it uh it was
pretty frustrating and definitely I
would say like one case where a point
that we make in the paper is that
services like this I think should um
really prioritize or be required to
prioritize I think some access to
researchers to look into kind of the
effects that their services are having
on the public um yeah and provide that
kind of minimal level of
support quick follow so are these
available for free or is it only like a
paid research type thing that you can
use the to API uh you have a very
limited quota for free and they did last
year after like two years of contacting
them and uh then after we launched our
or completed our study they do now have
a a YouTube for researchers portal which
I think you can get access to this this
at a greater level if you're a
researcher um I haven't used it
since well thank you for the talk uh uh
so just a quick question I think with
the switch mode versus the I
think uh for for that particular like
study of comparing the focus mode with
the explore mode I think the focus the
explore mode has worse search
capabilities and also just
recommendations so there's two factors
that there being a primary change would
you say or I mean I would say there's
even more than that there's like
autoplay there's no related
recommendations um so it really is kind
of a a bundle of features if you will
that we thought would influence sense of
control based on the survey that we did
previously we didn't you know test
individual features against each other
you could do that you'd have to have a
much larger sample size and SE
yeah so which one of these factors would
you think like ples the most effect in
kind of th driving the change or do you
think it's an an interaction effect
amongst all the vares that's yeah I'm
curious my guess would if I you know
just had speculate would be the visual
presence of recommendations all over the
place is probably the largest single
effect like when you open that app and
just see you know the wall of
recommendations um as well as
recommendations below below a video um
but we didn't test that so that would be
interesting to maybe try and tease a
part if you
could so I find the adaptable what you
call it adaptable Comm inter interface
yeah yeah a really
interesting Direction you know you you
motivated by one of the sort of user
interface almost like a nistic style
argument that you want to provide agency
and control that feels like it's in a
tradeoff with another one which is
another sort of classic result of HDI
which is no one changes
defaults and I'm wondering how you feel
like we should be navigating those so
you know do
you we can provide the control but if
most people don't make use of the
control is that going to help like how
how should we be thinking about that
design in the broader sense
there yeah you know that's something I'm
still grappling with because in this
study we had the toggle be manual but
you could certainly imagine it being
automated right based on some sort of
learning process of like we expect
you're here to do this right um and then
it would show either the focus or the
explore mode based on time of day and
you know past Behavior etc etc but you
might be then sacrificing of course some
of that sense of control over the
experience
um and so that is why we decided to go
manual here rather than actually sort of
fully
a just to be CLE there is you know when
it opens it's going to be in one mode or
the other and a lot of people aren't
going to switch it so I'm wondering how
we should navigate that um I don't do
you think that do you think for example
that the app should always open up in
the in the sort of focus mode or how do
we I I I honestly don't know so I'm just
curious like what do you feel would be
pragmatically what what we ought to do
here yeah one of the sort of
intermediate grounds that I think what
could be explored um because we found
that it wasn't the case that users
always wanted to explore or always
wanted to focus was that search often
functions as a signal of intent and
there are certain searches that I think
are like better aligned with the explore
mode and others that are better aligned
with Focus mode right and so then based
on that we might say okay well based on
your search it looks like we're going to
you know put you into explore mode and
based on your other search here about
the you know cooking this recipe
probably you know you don't want
unlimited recommendations forever
here okay thank you so I think that
would be an interesting way to sort of
get that user intent from the user with
some Agency on the part of the user as
well not entirely just inferring it from
past behaviors yeah okay I think we're
about at time so let's thank our
speaker